les écureuils sont des as du saut sans
filet des casse-cou prudent mais comment
arrive-t-il à sauter d'une branche à
l'autre sans tomber des chercheurs de
l'université bulk les et de l'université
du nebraska ont convié des écureuils à
faire le saut pour la science dans cette
forêt d'eucalyptus près du campus
californien des écureuils à la curiosité
dévorante vont livrer malgré eux une
partie de leurs secrets
au milieu des arbres différents
scénarios de sault s'échafaude ils vont
servir à mettre 10 curren à l'épreuve
les chercheurs sondent à la fois la
biomécanique du saut et le comportement
de l'animal
le défi des écureuils consiste à
accomplir des sceaux en échange d'une
récompense
comment juge-t-il de leurs capacités
atteindre leur cible sur quoi repose la
décision de sauter ou non et comment
adapter tinner sont
d'une épreuve à l'autre la flexibilité
du tremplin varient comme celle des
branches d'un arbre l'écureuil s'adapte
plus de tremplin et flexible plus il
prend son élan tôt
l'écureuil privilégier un point d'appui
rigide pour maximiser son impulsion
quitte à s'éloigner de sa cible
il adapte sa propulsion à la distance à
parcourir
selon les chercheurs l'écureuil accorde
six fois plus d'importance à la
flexibilité de la branche car la
distance à parcourir
une sorte de compromis calculé en
fonction des chances de succès de son
sceau si son évaluation est mauvaise et
que son centre de gravité est décalé par
rapport à la cible à atteindre il s'est
corrigé tirs il s'agrippe solidement à
la tige il fait demi tour par en dessous
la multiplication des sauts des essais
et des stratégies déployées révèle la
grande capacité d'apprentissage des
écureuils et leur sens de la créativité
comme celle d'utiliser en proie depuis
une paroi verticale sur leur route pour
ajuster leur vitesse et atteindre leurs
cibles plus efficacement
ce talent sans pareil des animaux
sauteurs à quoi alimenter les travaux
des roboticiens
un groupe de l'université mme clé a
justement mis au monde salto un petit
robot sauteur
inspiré au départ des galago petit
primate ses prouesses et ses trucs ne
sont pas sans rappeler celle des
écureuils comme quoi l'habileté des 1
stimule la créativité des ordres
[Musique]